hey martin what are you working on
hey abby i'm building a new web
application for teachers
and it will use cloud run is there an
easy way to get started
are you using visual studio code yes i
am
perfect let me show you how you can use
the cloud code extension to build a
starter app
run it locally and deploy to the cloud
all within minutes
all right so let's take a look at what
we've got here
uh okay so i created a project here in
cloud console
and uh created an empty folder on
on my local hard drive now i'm not sure
what to do next with cloud code you can
get a hello world app up and running
fast
cloud code has a repository of samples
that show best practices for a variety
of languages they're a good starting off
point and also a great reference for
seeing best practices in action
is there a language you're interested in
starting with yeah
let's build a node.js app
awesome first you'll need to install
cloud code
go ahead and click the extensions icon
all right
uh yep i did now type in cloud code
cloud
all right install installing
all right now there are new icons to the
left
and a cloud code button in your status
bar
uh yep okay let's get a hello world
node.js sample going
first click the cloud code button in the
status bar all right
then select new application uh new
application
yep cloud run cloud run application
yeah and node.js cloud run
node.js cloud run
okay hello world one sure put it there
ah it's downloading the sample great
all awesome it looks like there's some
code here index.js
and ah docker file here too that's great
because docker files are sometimes a
little hard to write
yep these samples can be built with both
docker or build packs
okay so abby you mentioned earlier that
i can run my cloud run service
locally how would i do that cloud code
comes with a cloud run emulator the
emulator
emulates the cloud run environment
locally to use it you'll need to have
docker installed first okay
let me do a quick search on how to do
that
install docker mac
okay docker desktop on mac
uh okay so uh i'll uh i'll install this
uh let's re-fill our tea
and meet back up in a few minutes sounds
good
all right i now have docker installed
and i've also started docker desktop
and i can even see a little docker
symbol up here in my toolbar
awesome let's try running this local way
now first let's make sure you're signed
in
click the cloud code cloud run button
all right
and now click that little login button
there uh click here to log in
yeah very good uh-huh something's
happening
oh look at that okay i want to pick this
account
uh okay view my data view and manage
compute engine resources
sure you are now authenticated with the
google cloud sdk
nice yay all right now back in vs code
uh let's go ahead and click the cloud
code button
at the bottom of the screen again in the
status bar
uh i seem to have the wrong project here
how do i change
project oh yeah oh you have to click
that little switch button
oh this one okay got it yeah let's see
teacher's aide okay yes
ah teacher's aid okay no cloud around
services in that project that sounds
about right
okay now i'll go ahead and click the
cloud code button at the bottom of the
screen
uh cloud code bottom of the screen okay
i'm here
yes and now click run on cloud run
emulator
okay run on the emulator
when setting it up you get the same
configuration options you'd see when
deploying to the cloud
except you're deploying locally to the
emulator
go ahead and in build settings let's
switch the builder
to build packs that way you'll get hot
reloading
this makes this makes the updating uh
come super fast
now pop open uh the show advanced
settings
to this emulate running on cloud run set
cpus to one virtual cpu
uh cpu one okay all right now scroll the
bottom and click run
okay let's see ah there it is run
first time you kick off the emulator can
take around five minutes
so go grab a snack to go with that tape
future runs will be much faster
all right abby uh looks like it's done
uh let's see
uh forward for url from service hello
world do i click this link here
yep let's have a look
oh look at that it's running yeah that
there
is your sample app running in the
emulator
awesome that was super easy uh so now
that it's running in the emulator
uh what happens if i make changes to my
code
go ahead and test it out um maybe try
updating
the main response on line 47 of your
index
your index.js file to return a simple
message
all right so right now it's compiling a
handlebars template or something a
template so
and outputting all the html from the
templates but i'll replace that so
instead it will say
hello world and i save that
oh something happened down here
uh looks like it just updated uh let me
refresh the browser
huh hello world it updated cloud code
supports hot reloading when building
node.js apps
with build packs which makes updates
take seconds
if you instead build with a docker file
a complete
rebuild and redeploy will happen which
isn't quite as fast
that update kicked off after saving
because you have watch mode turned on in
your run configuration
we just made it can be turned off at any
time if you don't like this feature
okay that wasn't too difficult the cloud
codes ui is really similar to cloud
console
so i uh but i plan on adding
data store to my cloud run service uh
can the cloud code extension help me
with that too
it actually can uh cloud code has an
integrated gcp
api explorer just click the cloud code
api icon
uh to the left there uh let's see it
says api here
is this the one yep okay
oh i see lots of google apis here uh
let's see databases databases uh oh
cloud data store api
there it is
all right now if you scroll down a
little here
oh it looks like um okay from here you
can enable the api with a click and read
up on how you can get it working
in your project it looks like datastore
is enabled by default which saves you a
click here
now go ahead and install the client
library
uh ah install client library uh let's
see not
java node.js
this little play button here
oh cool that runs npm installed for
the data store library
now we've got the data store npm package
installed here
and so i have i can use datastore
and then in the teacher's aid project
i had previously set up datastore and
put some data in
let me show you
so here i put in the kind course so
these are courses
and i put in two courses of our
trigonometry and calculus
all right now head back to vs code there
should be a handy documentation link to
help you get started with the data story
api
uh let's say invoke the api ah
documentation
let's go in and take a look at that
okay so here's some code for the cloud
datastore node.js client
looks good uh install the library okay
that happened already
make this a little bigger using the
client library okay
this looks promising uh it looks like
it's
creating a new entity that's not what i
want to do i want to read
my existing entities the trigonometry
and calculus
courses from the database let's see i'll
keep scrolling error handling
importing add tasks delete oh list tasks
that sounds good i'll click there
all right good here we have some code
that shows how to use the data store
library so i guess we need to declare
an import required data store at the top
of the code
so i'll copy that let's see
up here at the near the top of the code
paste those in data store okay require
data store
then it looks like there's a function
called list tasks it seems to run a
query against datastore okay
that's looking promising i'll just paste
that whole function in
here at the top as well and then i guess
this is just a function that isn't
called from anywhere
so uh i'll just at the
beginning of my main here i'll just call
it
and it's asynchronous so putting a
weight
there and it looks like the code
i'm looking at it here it prints stuff
to the console so it doesn't
uh it doesn't show anything to the user
in the browser but it
it prints to the server log says tasks
and then it goes over all the tasks in
the database
and prints them out in the server
console
so i'll just hit save again
and uh the output here
uh that should trigger the hot reloading
there aha
very nice i see that uh okay
and off to the server we go
localhost we reload this
very nice it still says hello world i
haven't broken anything
now where can i see my server logs these
console.log
statements so go ahead and go back to vs
code
and you see that little drop down there
that says cloud run run debug
click that yep and then switch to the
detailed view
oh detailed all right aha
very nice ah here's tasks that
corresponds to line 27 up here
very good and then it should loop over
all the tasks
and print them out here on line 30 but
it
doesn't seems like uh abby i have a bug
in my code here
uh i expect to see the names of my
courses trigonometry and calculus
is there a way to debug this error oh
yeah
first go ahead and click that stop
button at the top there okay
stop now make sure you have
debug toggle auto attach set to smarter
always
all right debug toggle auto attach
ah it's set to smart already good yep
and this makes this makes it so that we
can
attach to the running application for
debugging
uh now place a break point at the
problem spot
okay so i think here on line 26
this is where we read the elements
records from the database so maybe i'll
place a breakpoint here on 27 so we can
inspect what the tasks variable contains
all right looks good so now let's go
ahead and click that cloud code status
bar again
all right uh cloud code ah there it is
yeah and then click debug
on cloud run emulator ah debug i see it
yep now we're going to debug this
locally
oh it's uh switched back to visual
studio code
i'm in the debugger here i see that
because it's orange
status bar and oh look it hit my
breakpoint breakpoint on 27.
so let's see here okay tasks that's what
i wanted to look at
so tasks is an array okay that's good oh
an array of lengths zero
so it's not getting anything from the
database
oh i think i know why here i'm looking
for the task
entity in the database and my database
doesn't have task entities they have
course entities so i'll copy that
and i will look for course entities
and i won't sort them by created i will
sort them by
because i don't have it created they
have name however so i'll sort them by
name
name there we go all right i'm saving
all right so watch mode doesn't work
while debugging
so go ahead and to view your bug fix
let's detach our debugger
by clicking that little unplug button up
there okay unplugging
and hit stop stop
now i'll click that cloud code sas bar
again
all right
and then let's run cloud run emulator
one more time
one more time all right
it looks like it started running uh i'll
hit that localhost url
again
okay it says hello world good nothing is
broken
and now i'll go back and check the
server logs
so you said they were in detail right
yep let's have a look oh look
name trigonometry very nice and
name calculus and sort it by name
awesome cool you fixed the bug yeah
very nice so this little service is
looking
great now if i want to deploy it to the
cloud
do i have to figure out those uh tricky
g cloud
nope cloudco can do that for you just
like with running on the emulator
cloud packages deploying to the cloud in
a couple clicks
go ahead and click on that cloud code
status bar again and select
deploy to cloud run okay cloud code
deploy to cloud run
you can see all the service options go
ahead and keep all the defaults and just
click to play
uh the docker docker ah there we go
deploy
i'm deploying
and it's now building your container
image pushing it to your container
registry
and deploying to cloud run managed
oh looks like it's done go ahead and
click that link
ah hello world at run.app
alright cool let's see
now this is your service running on
cloud run anyone can access it now
woohoo feels great to finally get
something running on cloud run
and not having to type any gcloud
commands can you do anything else
uh cloud run related with a cloud code
extension
yes now that you have a cloud run
service you can view its details from
the cloud run explorer
let's go ahead and go back to vs code
and click that
cloud code cloud run button oh okay
yep and if you there okay there we go
there's your service
so if you go ahead and expand that drop
down there on your service
here's where you can view quick details
about your service like traffic
allocation and its url
what's even cooler is being able to view
the logs of your cloud run service from
your ide
go ahead and hover over your service
real quick uh
up here yep and now click that little
logging button to the right
uh ah yes this means logging oh view
logs it says tool
all right
okay so i get to set up filters what
logs i want to
view these look like reasonable defaults
i want to see my cloud run logs and that
has been
selected here
yep you also grabbed it for your service
so these are all the logs from your
service
aha and look at that there is my good
old friend
trigonometry and there is calculus
it works hey abby uh thanks for showing
me how to run and debug
my cloud run service locally and how to
deploy it with
one click yeah the cloud code extension
makes things pretty simple be sure to
install the cloud code extension from
the vs code marketplace and give it a
try
let us know in the comments what you
think about it sounds good
see you next time
you